ازمه خنقه تواجهها بريطانيا في نظامها
الصحيه تواجه الحكومه جراء اجراء عفوا
جراها اتهامات بالتقاعس فيما يحول رئيس
الوزراء ريشي سوناك ايجاد حل لها وللتخفيف
وطاه ازمه القطاع عقد سوناك اجتماع عن
طارها مع خبراء ومسؤولين عن قطاع الصحه
يوم امس وادعى سوناك خلال الاجتماع الي
نهج جريء وجذري لايجاد حلول للازمه الحاده
التي يشهدها النظام الصحي في البلاد
ويعاني النظام الصحه العامه نقصا في
التمويل منذ سنوات واكتضاض خدمات الطوارئ
في المستشفيات جراء حالات الانفلونزا
وكرونا بالاضافه الى حالات الانتظار
الطويله لاجراء العمليات الجراحيه
واصتحركه احتجاجيه للممرضات والمسعين على
خلفيه ازمه ارتفاع تكاليف الحياه وفي
محاوله لانهاء الاضرابات التي تؤثر في
القطاع في قطاع الصحه والقطاعات الاخرى
وادعه الحكومه البريطا ايضا النقابات الى
اجراء مناقشات يوم الاثنين